As lengthy as the run time was for Avengers:
Infinity War, there's still more of the movie
we didn't see, and directors Joe and Anthony
Russo have indicated that fans can expect
plenty of bonus material to come in the take-home
copies of the film.
Although they've yet to spell out exactly
which deleted and extended scenes could be
included, they, along with the film's cast,
have shared a few hints about what might be
missing from the movie's theatrical version.
Here's a look at some of the Avengers: Infinity
War scenes that might make the DVD extras,
and a few that may never see the light of
day.
Guardians get silly
One missing scene the Russo brothers have
promised involves the Guardians of the Galaxy
flexing their funny bones.
Anthony Russo told Entertainment Weekly:
"It's a scene where they're sort of stuck.
There's a point in the movie where they're
stuck without knowing what to do.
… it was really fun and it was very endearing
to us.
But because the movie is so big and so propulsive,
it just wasn't quite pushing us where we needed
to go."
That description indicates this is an extension
of the scene on Knowhere when Peter Quill,
Drax, and Mantis are duped by Thanos' reality
stone trickery and left to fester on the broken
planet.
Russo confirmed as much in a later interview
with ComicBook.com, saying:
"It's at that moment in the movie where they
have lost Gamora to Thanos in the Knowhere
and they don't know what to do about it.
They don't know where to go.
They have no idea what to do.
And it serves as this very absurd scene about
the Guardians not knowing what to do, that's
very, very funny."
In other words, expect to see some more humor
from the Star-Lord that might help make fans
less mad at him.
"Wow."
Pepper & Co. in the park
In one of the earliest scenes from Infinity
War, Tony Stark can be seen taking a walk
with his lady love Pepper Potts as the two
discuss his dream about her being pregnant
before he runs off to deal with Thanos' looming
threat.
That exchange may have been a mere primer
for what's still to come between the two in
Avengers 4, but it was also an abbreviated
version of what was actually filmed.
Screenplay co-writer Christopher Markus told
GameSpot that there were a lot more people
who joined the fray for that scene, saying:
"We shot an unbelievably long version of Tony
and Pepper in the park that features cameos.
It was sort of Robert and his friends' day
at the park."
Judging from behind-the-scenes footage taken
during the shoot, Happy may be one of the
missing persons we can expect to see in the
fuller version.
"Go team, yeahhhh."
Hulkbuster smash?
Much has been made of the fact that Bruce
Banner was unable to transform into the Hulk
on cue in Avengers: Infinity War.
But there may be reason to believe another
version of the film might've featured Hulk
going berserk in the Hulkbuster suit.
While we know that the trailer's big tracking
shot was made specifically to mislead audiences
about what was to come on the Banner-Hulk
front in the Battle of Wakanda, there are
other glimpses from the trailer that seem
to indicate some Hulk smashing as well.
For example, there's a moment in the first
trailer when Bruce is shown standing next
to a broken version of the Hulkbuster suit,
looking a little embarrassed.
Although there's no official indication that
a Hulk in the Hulkbuster suit scene was shot,
the fact that Funko Pop released a toy version
of the green giant breaking through the red
get-up has led some fans to believe it points
to yet another scene that didn't make the
final cut of the film but might find its way
into your home copy.
Now, let's talk about a few of those scenes
that were thought up but never produced...
A Civil War reunion
Perhaps the most disappointing aspect of Avengers:
Infinity War is that it didn't fully resolve
the conflict between Iron Man and Captain
America.
Sure, there's a detente between the two that
comes by way of flip phone, but the two don't
share the screen, even though they're fighting
for the same team again.
According to co-writer Stephen McFeely, however,
at least one draft of the film's script would've
brought them back together at last.
He told Yahoo Movies:
"Our first sort of wonky draft [featured]
the idea that they had to get back in the
same room together.
That meant that you're slowing down your Thanos
Stones plot to deal with other threads from
other movies.
As much as we wanted to do it, and as many
times as we wrote those scenes, [it] became
clear that this movie needed to be propulsive
and be about Thanos and what he represented
to the Avengers."
It's not over yet, however, and Joe Russo
has teased that Captain America: Civil War
contains a big hint about what's to come in
Avengers 4.
So, now that Iron Man has been left alone
on Titan, perhaps the next film will finally
bring their face-to-face scene to fruition.
"Let's go."
The power stone
While Avengers: Infinity War showed how Thanos
acquired most of the Infinity Stones, we didn't
get to see him claim the Power Stone, which
had previously been left in the care of the
Nova Corps on Xandar.
According to McFeely, the scene was originally
written into the film, but had to be edited
out of the working script for the sake of
streamlining the story.
As he explained to Yahoo!
Movies:
"I do remember, there was a Xandar draft,
and it just became unwieldy.
It's lovely to go back to a small part of
Guardians of the Galaxy and explore how you
get that stone, but we had to eventually economize."
So instead of seeing the Mad Titan destroy
that planet, we only get to hear about it
secondhand.
Similarly, fans also never get to find out
exactly how he snagged the Reality Stone,
because the Guardians don't arrive until after
he's collected the Aether from the Collector.
The next chapter
Since Avengers: Infinity War and Avengers
4 are two parts of one overarching narrative,
there was bound to be at least a little confusion
over which scenes were filmed for which movies,
and some of the cast's interviews reflect
as much … or do they?
There have been several instances of Avengers
stars discussing production on scenes that
we haven't seen yet.
"Did you thrust your hand towards someone
wearing like a blue suit with ping pong glued
on."
"Yes."
"Then you still have powers."
One of the biggest points of confusion seems
to center around whether a giant group scene
would be included in Infinity War or the next
film.
"In one particular scene there's like 32 of
us.
There's a lot.
There's so many of us I don't even know who's
a Marvel character and who's a crew member."
Mark Ruffalo implied he'd worked with Tilda
Swinton and Cate Blanchett, which made folks
believe the Ancient One and the Goddess of
Death would make an appearance at some point.
And Sebastian Stan said it included everyone
from Nick Fury to Janet Van Dyne.
Even the Russos seemed to be confused about
where it'd end up; they agreed there'd be
a Civil War airport-sized scene in Infinity
War, with Joe Russo saying:
"We have like an equivalent that's like, you
know if you had a comic book and you open
it up to your double panel and then you fold
it out.
And then you folded it out again and again."
Since nothing like that came through in Infinity
War, we just have to believe it's being reserved
for round four instead.
But we'll have to wait 'til next year to find
out for sure.
"Boom."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!